Mr. President! Nuclear missiles will
strike our country in 14 minutes.
I know it’s yourfirst day in office so I’m going
to walk you through it, but you’re the only one
who canauthorize our nuclear retaliation in
response and you’ve only got a
few minutes to make a decision!
As you know tensions have escalated
rapidly in the past few days.
Today’s joint allied aerial defenseexercise
began just minutes before we detectedthe launch.
A simple misunderstanding maybe.
We assume the sudden attack is meant to neutralize
as many of our nuclearforces as possible.
But that doesn’t matter now – missiles are in
the air and we can’t shoot all of ‘em down.
Why? BecauseIntercontinental ballistic
missilesare basically rockets launched into space
beforere-entering the atmosphere over their
target andreleasing many different warheads.
Higher andfaster than anything
you can send after them.
We need to get you to the bunker!
Here is what we know: Four minutes ago
our new infrared monitoring satellites
detectedone hundred twelve bursts consistent with
ICBM launches from the enemy’s inner territories.
For some reason only 20 of their 80 underground
nuclear silos seem to have fired, so we suspect
most of them were transporter-erector launchers,
you know: trucks with big missiles on them.
It’sunclear why they didn’t
use all their silos – they
might just not work after more than thirtyyears
or they might be keeping them in reserve. The
fog of war is keeping many things unclear!
Aerospace Command thinks the ICBMs are
targeting our nuclear command centers,
silos, and major airforce and navy bases,
ending this war before we have a chance toact!
The enemy’s strategic doctrine prioritizes
military targets and our nuclear weapon
systems, but their secondary targets are our
industry and infrastructure – oil refineries,
power stations and deep water ports. All
located near or in major population centers.
We won’t know the exact
casualty count for a few weeks.
Deaths from the blastand burns
may be a few million today.
It’smorning rush hour and there’s not much
to be done for people stuck in traffic.
Peoplein major metro areas can’t really
evacuate, but emergency broadcasts are
being sent out to shelter in place and away
from windows. Radiation exposure for intact
population centers is highly dependent
on the weatherover the next week.
We might be looking at dozens of millions
of deaths by the end of the month.
For the next few minutes we can
stillrespond, but –
You need to decide!
We’ve got 1500 warheads across our
silos, bombers, and submarines.
The 400 in silosneed to be launched now
before theyget taken out.
46 nuclear capable bomberson high alert
can be ready to take off in 2minutes –
though we need to transmit the order now
to get them out of the blast radius
ifyou want to consider using them.
Of our 14 nuclear submarines,
5 are presently atsea.
While they’re submerged they’re
undetectable, so that’s our
back-up for a nuclear retaliation
if we lose our silos and bombers.
We could try to use them
to bomb out their remaining
silo fieldsbefore they can launch them.
The sooner you committo it,
the better the chance we have
of preventinga further
exchange after our retaliation.
Updates!
We have radar confirmation that the enemyICBMs
have completed their burn
and deployedtheir warheads.
Our best guess is that each missile will
deploy at least 6 re-entry vehicles,
about 600 in total, which is the part that
carries a warhead back into the atmosphere
during its terminal descent onto the target
– and with many more decoys on top of that,
inflatableballoons meant
to waste any anti-missiles.
We’renow tracking nearly 4000 potential targets.
Our anti-ballistic missiles have been launched
and will begin their intercept in another minute.
We’ll do our best to protect the capital,
although there really is no defense.
Wait… confirming a partial radar
blackout, our systems seem to be glitchy.
The enemy must haveanticipated we’d launch our
interceptors and pre-detonated
a few warheads at highaltitude.
That ionizes the atmosphere
and createsradar interference.
Our interceptorsshould still operate okay,
they’ve had a 55% success rate in
tests but never with this manydecoys
or with radar interference thisintense.
We might shoot down 50 objects,
but there’s no guarantee they’re warheads.
Itlooks like most bombs are going to get through.
This is our last chance to counterattack.
We’re out of time. Our silo launch
sequence takes 5 minutes. We have to
transmit and confirm a launch order
and themissile needs time to clear
the blast radius of the incoming bomb.
This is a lot to take in,
but the warplan is made,
you just need to enterthe
launch authorization codes
and pushthis button to transmit them!
You can’tdo anything else
to save more ofour people.
If you don’t launch now thenthis war will be
over before it even begins –
you understand this is our one chance, right?
The effect? Enemy civilian casualties are hard
to estimate, but should be similar to ours
– afew million right away, perhaps a few
tens of million by the end of themonth.
The total fallout from their attacks
and ours might trigger a nuclear winter,
potentially killing billions around the world –
but that might happen even if we don’t retaliate.
I’m sure you have questions butyou have
to give orders withoutexpecting
answers right now.
Withan attack of this scale there’s noguarantee
communications or assetswill
be intact in a few minutes.
We’re out of time, we need a
decision Sir. Can we launch?
Nuclear wars aren’t regular wars. They
only last minutes, and in times of crisis,
small conflicts can rapidly spiral out of
control. Anything from small communicationlags
to sensor errors to just uncertainty and the
fog of war mean that no leader will ever have
a complete idea of what’s happening as a crisis
unfolds. When tensions are high, accidents or
misunderstandings can steer leaders - even those
with good intentions - to launch a nuclear attack.
Confused and with incomplete
information,a single person
– yes, it's really just ONE
single person who decides –
can literallymake civilization-ending decisions
killinghundreds of millions of people in
the time it takes to watch a YouTube video.
This story is fiction, but the world
came very close to this several times.
In 1995 Russian radar detected a submarine
launched missile and their nuclear forces went
on full alert, except it was actually
a scientific rocket to study auroras.
In 1979,US computers reported a full scale
Soviet attack with only minutes torespond
– except it was a training tape being
incorrectly loaded into a computer.
In 1983,the Soviet satellite alert system
showed five ICBMs launched from the US.
But it wasa false alarm caused by
sunlight reflectedon clouds.
During the Cuban Missile Crisis,
a Soviet submarine with no contact to
Moscow for several days concluded that
nuclear war had begun and decided
to launch a nuclear torpedo.
Luckily the authorization
ofthree officers was required.
One of them, VasilyArkhipov, opposed it.
But what if he hadn’t?
Any safeguard can fail, no matter
how carefully designed it might be.
And decisions are beingmade right now
to build new weapons and missilesystems
that commit the world to another
centuryof nuclear stalemate,
complicated further byChina's emergence
as a new nuclear superpower.
Simply accepting that the existence of nuclear
weapons is inevitable might
mean their use isinevitable.
But the world doesn’t have to be
this way. Even incremental steps,
taking apart one bomb at a time, will
eventually result in a world with none.
During the Cold War, the world had over
70,000 nuclear weapons
– through arms reduction treaties,
that number is now about 12,500.
Progressis not guaranteed,
but it’s also not impossible.
Governments and militaries are not separate
from their nations, they’re part of them,
just like you. You have the power to
make demands of your leaders and often
this begins with just being aware of
an issue. If you want to learn more,
we've compiled a number of resources for you
in the video description and our sources.
This video was supported by Open Philanthropy.
Did you know that there are countless more
kurzgesagt videos that we upload on TikTok,
Youtube Shorts and Instagram Reels? Byte-sized
information, animated facts and inspiring thoughtexperiments.
After all, you also need videos you
can watch quickly in a bathroom break!
Our longer,more in depth videos are happening here on
Youtube – Short form is a completely differentchallenge
that we are trying to do as well as
possible – check them out if you are curious!
And if you want to discuss and share your thoughts
about Science with other like-minded people,
why don’t you check out ourDiscord community
with over80,000 birbs?
We have channels where you
can chat about STEM topics,
participatein events and the
“academic questionof the week”
… and we have the best emotes!
After all, we want to spark your curiousity,
but it’s always more fun to be
curious together! See you over there!